ADVISERS ANDIME LOI     YALISTS
IS MS EFE  TO JUMP IN TH
PRESIDEN RACE.NE
DEFUND DIVERSITY BILL
COLL, ONSE TO
TAOOMS.AN FLORIDA LAW
TO A TE G ASOVNCY OVER STATE
SPENDING AND TRAVEL.
DeSANTISEP
RFO STATES
RUN BY DEMOCRAPRN
D DEATH.GED IN THE S
THRNS.HIS WEEKEND WHEN THE 45th
MPE
INDIRECTLYSANTIS.
E CULTURE OF
THAT S INFECTIN RECENT YEARS.
IF WN TH OR ON OTHER SIDE ISSUES
RESPONSE IN A NEW W ANCLARED, Q
CAUGHT UP IN THE PAST. I'M
RON'S A  R, WOULDN'T HAVANTIS W.
>>AT LAST HOWEVER MANY
ELECTION CYCS,8.
WETHTHE SENATE
S PRESSE
WE LTHE SENATE IN
BIDEN BECOMEESIDENT AND HAS OUF.
AND WE WERE SUO HAVE IS BIG R W
AND , FLORIDA
WAVE A COUNTRY., I THINK THE PAF
>> JOINING ME SER STEVE RT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOPROGRAM, SAA
ME.
>> ALL RIGHTSTEVE, WRTER O PRES
ANFOE AMERICA FIRST IDENT TRUM
NT BROADLY FANY YE
W BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
AND BY THAT, I MEAN  I T VENT
BELIEVTH
IST ELECTABLE,OST TIVE CANDIDAUI
OSSIBLE.
HE HAS PROVEATCO
AND FOTH R
THE PERSONAL RISK HERE OF
ADVOCATI F UNDERDOG,RENEGADE, W.
ASK
DAN NICKIANNI HAS T
ALLY ANNED
RUNNING FOR PRANE QUESTION IS D
KNOWOMNGT KNOW YES, I AM
PL THIS, OR GIVIYOU AN
HE'S G TNOT PRIVATNVERSATIONS WH
RON DeSA.,
OBERL CONCLUDE THANTIS IS DOINGT
MAKE THIS RUR OF
FULLY EXPECT T
AND WEEKS.NG DAY
D I AM PERLL
EXCITED .
N,HE COUNTRY IS
IN A VERY MIOD RIGHT
NO
OPINION.OT STEVETEZ'
WT E RELEVA
S USPEA X L SAY THE ON
GETTR FAMILY.
RCH
VI
DE TRUMP LIKES IT. KNOW E ENPOL.
, 70%  TRILE DNTRE
TRUMP TO RUN AGAIN.0% OF NBC PO
AGAIN.
SO, HOW DO WBRIS
POLITICAL G JAM SO WE CAN  T
BELIEVE THE MOST CREDIBL
TION, THECDOTE, THIS YOUNG MAND
G E T INTO A
RUBY REDEPUBLICAN ATD YOED DONAA
CERTAIWAA DISRUPTER.
BUT HE OF
THE NOS DENCY ORICAL PT.
HE WAS AIAD A LOT.
WAS A PSI SDIVISION ANGER.
AND TRUMP DENIES BUT THERE
E WHO  D OFEDUS WHO SAID THEY B
DONALD TRUMP FORTHE YOU BE OKA
ACTE SE WAY MER
PRT TRUMP?
WELL, RAH, YOD I ARE
I DO NOT THINK TT
DISRUPTER WE NEEDED --
>> HE HAGHY
TO.
HAS BEEN CAUGHTR N.
GILIE, A LET'S
DISCUSS IT.
>> THERE ARE TOO MANY OF THEM TR
LITERA TO RECO
I .
T US TABISPUBLICAN PARAS BEEOR R
PRO-BUSINESS.LORICALAS
T G  HE HA
DOICH IS BALAN
TO PUT IATDOESN'T ALLOOP
WAY HE WENT MONESO OF TH
THE STATE -- USINGOM
STATE RESOURCES, LIKE
EOPLE E TO LOOHATRANSPEN
THEOF
FLORIDA. DO YOU THINK ABOUT THA.
WELL,  TPART
OF YOUR QUESTION, REGARDING  TA
BUSINESS, YES, HISTORICALLY THE
THAT IS NOT E
WORKER,
RON DeSANTIS HAS SHOWN
CUICD TO IERNTA --
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT IT'
APPROPRIE CH S
HILDREN.
OF FLORIDMA NOT.
AND SN T I
MPOSE ITS
WILL ON THE PEOPLE OF
GIANT NOND PAR YOUR CH BACK AR
QUESTIONEGARDING --
>>E JUMPN HERE
ES
GOVERNOR --
>> I JUST WANT TABT SNANS FOR S
PROINESS,
>> YESE IS -- , D THAT IS ANSSE
THAT THEEPY
S FAR MOREIS RO WORKEIN THE PAS
BUT HERE'S T REALITY.NESS IN THF
GOVERNMENTERARLY G
BUT THERE ARE MANY OTHER AREAS .
WE'RE BIG SS AND
GOVERNMENT WORK ON
COUNTRMA WAYS,AS
SLOUCHED INTIG
E FEW.
WE HIFFERENT VISION EFUSEDHETUAT
TAKE ON BIG BUSS
WOULD USE IS O-
AND RISE HASBSELUSINESS.RO
THE STATE OFORE PEOPLE AND
BUSINESSES ARE FLOCKING IN
FLORIDA BECAOF RON DTIS S AT HE
BUILT.A
F UNWELCG
ATER.
BUT TH MIGRATI ONGD COMPANIES
POINTO TTELLS US EXACTLY THE OP.
PEOPLE HAVE RALLIED TO TDeSANTI-
G THE OTHER
ALKEOUTRANALLY
CIOF TRANSPARENCY
AND MORE TRANSPARENCIN
GOVERNMENT.
WOEXELO LAIMED EXECUTIVE WE TAL
AVSTATE'BURE LAW
IDA.AVE THE SUNSHINES IN
WHTHISOU THAT HE SHOUL
IN THIS SIO SAY,,
T SEE  SPENT
SOME OF THE ATHEAY, OR YOU C'TH
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE ISIM
IMPOANAINLY FOR A
OR.
AS YOU WELL KNOWA GOV NA T W AND
HE HAS TAYDIFFERENSUMING HE DOE
DON'T E EXECUT IS USUALLY SET A.
O RALLIED TO HIS A
CAN ABSOLUTELY
BY THE WAY, ONE WITH COAT T A S
VICTORY, BUT ALSO LIFTED ALL
OTHEATWI OFFICESTIME TICES ARE
THE PEOPLE OF FL